so all these axes we've got this
eccentricity number okay we're almost
ready to turn right I'm going to make a
really really tricky argument on one
color on this diagram and I need to put
some points on here okay I am trying to
get towards a relationship between these
numbers here and the equation that I end
up getting so a B and in a kind of world
the action is happening right as you'll
see in a minute so I need to put some
points onto the piece of paper why don't
you add on three points on to keep and
I'm going to give him some names so I've
got a couple of points here there are
the extremities of the major axis major
axis that's the axis which is are
defined by a so be this divided by a I'm
gonna call these two points a one and A
two these capital letters for points
usually mathematicians easily spend that
way you get distinction
secondly I've got this other point over
here which is on the directrix okay now
I actually usually do some capital D or
the directrix and they use lowercase D
for distance so it's a kid make sure
that we just call that guy cause what
are the pointy bits kind of already on
there that's the origin maybe you want
to put you there just a highlight now if
I know that by definition I have a look
at this by definition if ps4 PV equals
the X inches that's the ratio right then
I can start doing algebra is try
assuming this you agree with that
yeah he's the thief these are the point
in a one and A two
I didn't just pick them as random points
right anyone at a to represent points on
the walkers point satisfy this and n
represents that direction so I can get
some distance compared to there because
everywhere along PR all I need to work
out like the distance from here to the
focus is just that straight line it's
horizontal it's nice and easy to work
out and the distance introduces that
straight line also very easily so by
definition because of this right I'm
going to say this one for a 1 and 1 for
a 2 so here we go I've got yes what is
that distance that represents penis when
the particular point I want is this guy
right are you okay with that so that's
the left hand side of the equation
that's a particular pain SPS that should
be equal to e yes
by definition times the other distance
what's this distance here the distance
of ejectment it's
if the distance from Y point to the
directrix it's the shortest distance per
cup of the students is that one right
there
a one
now I can make exactly the same thing
but cut me too because in my base it's
on the locker so it abates the same
geometric more so I'm gonna say this
and now I have two questions okay now
this doesn't look like there's much
obviously too young right remember what
I'm trying to get to what is a
relationship between all of these if I
can understand through a 1 and a 2
they're connected to this lowercase a so
this will get me a relationship right
when you have someone in a situation
it's what kind of strategies do you have
to simplify things you want to combine
them in some way like the elimination or
substitution okay now there's nothing
obvious it's going to eliminate here
that's okay stay with it
the first thing I'm going to do rather
than the many I will get to that but
that's actually because I'm just going
to add these together just gonna happen
so if I go one plus two I'm gonna get
this guy on the left
so fast of you
now hold on a second I can do a lot of
factorizing here at all so I can take
advantage of a lot of the geometry
that's inherent in this ellipse so for
example if I if I don't look at this and
I say okay I can do some factorizing
right do you agree with that have a look
what can i factor eyes out I can
vectorize out now be careful because
what is this right this is not s21 right
so even though it looks like this
factorization you there is not this
factorization over here though so that's
okay I can factor out a it's being
multiplied by that and that you agree
with that but there are no factors here
these are not products however this is
something else or they get it carefully
right do you see s a one is here and s a
2 is here hold on a second when I put
those two together what do I get I get
the major axis which is two-way do you
agree that so so stay with me right
these are true parts of the major axis
and when I advent
okay good that's good
that was an easy one to see this one not
so much so look at it really carefully
if you have yet another color I know
you're probably money nothing I am okay
I'm gonna go where are these intervals
on my diamond a 1 a 1 n is here right an
a2 all the way from over there here they
like so how are you just gonna I'm gonna
buy that matrix it's something you guys
nobody's know and it's gonna go straight
across
do you agree that that's what I've got a
1 M plus a two minute that now look
really carefully right because of like
I'm trying to simplify things much like
last weekend right
like putting together like combining
distances do you see this distance here
a right is the same as this 8 here
do you agree that those are the same
because the symmetrical right so what
I'm going to do is under stopping here
and I'm just going to shift it here you
care with that to same distance isn't it
so now you see when I add these two red
intervals together it's much simpler to
say it as double because I've got two of
them this distance ooh don't want that
okay we made some sous advances here
right because look at this right we have
come down very far and now we know
something about oh and right because a
and E they are just constants do you
agree with that like there's some
numbers like oh like this or like this
they're just gonna be some nonlinear fun
so if I rearranged a little bit I can do
some canceling yeah
cancel cancel and if I just say well
what's ahead now
what's that distance and the answer is
it's a on 8 June look at that isn't that
a beautiful look I've worked out this
distance here it's a 1:8 but that tells
me exactly how far the origin is from
the directrix that implies that the
equation of this line is executed a
sonic sense so if I know what and a are
what hammer are then I know where the
directrix is in fact once I know what
where one directrix is I know where the
other one is to write this is going to
be the same theme but reflected the
other way you can with that so I have
the equations of the director sees out
of here right
so therefore the equations of the
director sees x equals plus or minus
because there's two of them
now you get what I said you know what
our strategies have put these things
together and I said okay go ahead and
try an avid game this is what falls out
okay now I want you to try subtracting
them and see what you can get try and
try and do as soon on your three you're
going to rely on your diagram a heck of
a lot that's okay right
what happens when you take one equation
from the other just for the sake of
consistency so we're all sort of paying
towards the same direction
let's do take away one I mean you can't
do one take away two but do you do you
see by the way there's a logical reason
why don't you take away one round the
other way why in this plus x1 it's
bigger yeah good SI toos is that right
I've chosen that as a normal one so it
kind of if I want makes it positive I'm
going to choose you gonna take away
smaller
otherwise I'll just have a double
negative no you're gonna try that to see
what you get